>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Grant Harris: Father Lush
Gjergji is a Roman Catholic priest
in Kosovo where he was born.
He has known Mother Teresa, now
Saint Mother Teresa, since 1968.
He was ordained in 1973.
And his 1975 doctorate
in psychology is
from the Sapienza University
of Rome.
He has authored over 60 works
on psychology and religion,
as well as 16 books dedicated to
the life, works, and spirituality
of Saint Teresa of Kolkata.
He will discuss her life and works,
as well as her Albanian origins.
Father Lush writes in
Albanian, Italian, and Croatian,
so he's quite multilingual.
English would not be
his strong language,
so we have a wonderful
interpreter here for this event.
Father Lush's works have
been translated into English
and several other languages.
His talk, as I said, will
be interpreted for us.
So I will turn this over to you.
Thank you so much for being here.
I should also say Father
Lush has donated four works
about Mother Teresa to the Library
of Congress today,
and he signed them.
And so, later, if you want
to look at those, please do.
Please leave them for me.
Saint Teresa will not be
happy if you take those away.
[ Laughter ]
But thank you, and thank
you for being here today.
[ Applause ]
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Father Lush Gjergji:
Dear friends, spiritual sons
and daughters of Mother Teresa.
[ Foreign Language ]
I firstly greet the Albanian
ambassador that is here,
and all of the diplomats, and each
one of the VOA representatives,
and each one of you
here that have come.
I warmly greet you, and I
want to give you my thanks
that you are here today to
honor Saint Mother Teresa.
[ Foreign Language ]
I also want to thank the
Albanian-American community,
without whom this would
not have been possible.
But also, Mr. Grant Harris,
the chief responsible person
for organizing this event in
this temple of knowledge to come
and to honor Mother Teresa.
Thank you.
[ Foreign Language ]
My presentation is titled "Daughter
of Albania, Mother to the World,
and now the Saint of
Love, Mother Teresa".
[ Foreign Language ]
I didn't think to start any
better rather than use the line
from the sacred scripture from
Saint Luke the Evangelist, who said,
"Blessed is she who has believed
that the Lord would fulfill
His promises to her."
Luke 1:45.
[ Foreign Language ]
I've synthesized the
Albanian sentiment,
but also the humanity
sentiment with the headline
"The centuries had been
waiting and preparing,
but we lived the experience of her."
[ Foreign Language ]
In order to understand the person
as an individual in a relation
to family, society,
nationality, faith and culture,
one must consider the surroundings,
environment, and living conditions.
Because without these distinguishing
characteristics, the roots,
we may somehow lose the essence
of the identity or personality.
I've met Mother Teresa Bojaxhiu
many times over the course
of our long friendship, working
together in different hemispheres
around the globe since my first
meeting with her face-to-face
in the fall of 1968 in Rome.
[ Foreign Language ]
At that time, I was a student
in my second year of philosophy
at Pontifical Urban University.
I accompanied her on all five
of her visits to Kosovo --
1970, '78, '80, 1982, and 1986.
I was with her in Oslo in 1979 when
she received the Nobel Peace Prize,
many times in Eastern Europe,
in particular to Kolkata
and the neighboring
countries in 1989.
Every time I met her, it seemed like
the first time and the last time.
I was struck by her simplicity,
genuineness, kindness, generosity,
patience, caring and love for the
poorest of the poor, the lepers,
the unwanted, and her
longing for the homeland,
that strong spiritual link with
the Albanian people and the church.
But also her suffering
with us and for us,
as well as for all the
peoples of the world.
[ Foreign Language ]
I've investigated and
researched her foundation,
the origin of this
profound and passionate love
and dedication for the whole world.
My conclusion is this --
there are two unique sources
that had prepared her to
be gifted to the world.
Her family's life experiences and
the inherited ancient traditions
of the Albanian people,
which are based on these holy
and meaningful principles.
First, bread, salt, and heart.
As well, the house belongs
to God and to the guest.
Along with life filled
with Christian love,
both in her household
and in the parish
where Christ's words
meant for all run through.
"What you do for the least of
my brothers, you do for me."
Matthew 25:40.
[ Foreign Language ]
She was love in action.
That is how I have defined her.
With 16 books dedicated to
Mother Teresa translated
into many languages,
I've tried to dissect
and document these two bottomless
wells for Mother Teresa --
God, love for brother and
sister, and for all humanity.
[ Foreign Language ]
I'll continue with my presentation
with some questions that might
as well be burning
questions for you as well.
And I will try and give
some answers to those.
So my first question is,
"Who was Gonxhe Bojaxhiu?"
[ Foreign Language ]
Gonxhe Bojaxhiu was a daughter
of Kolë Bojaxhiu,
originally from Prizren.
And Drane Bojaxhiu, her maiden name,
was Barnaj from Novo
Sella outside Gjakovës.
But more than that, Mother
Teresa was the daughter
of our 2000-year-old Christianity,
the daughter of Albanian
tradition, culture, and martyrdom.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question is, "How is
it that she was born in Skopje?"
Gonxhe Bojaxhiu's family was
uprooted from Prizren and forced
to relocate to Skopje due to Turkish
persecution against Albanians,
especially those of the Catholic
faith because of various diseases
that befell Prizren,
particularly the cholera epidemic
that reduced the city's population
in half between the years 1850
to 1855, and like other families in
search of better work opportunities.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question,
"Who were her parents?"
Kolë Bojaxhiu -- born
in 1872, died in 1919 --
was a well-known merchant,
a builder, musician,
polyglot, a true patriot.
But above all, he was a chartable
man and father to the poor
of Skopje and surrounding areas.
He paid for his activism
and equality and rights
with his own life as he
was apparently poisoned
in Belgrade simply because he
defended basic human rights,
especially those of the Albanians.
[ Foreign Language ]
Drane Bojaxhiu was born in 1889 and
died in 1972 in Tirana, Albania.
She was a good woman, a caring
homemaker, a dedicated mother,
and a pious soul
with a compassionate heart
for everyone in need.
She was Gonxhe Bojaxhiu's
first teacher.
The Bojaxhiu family had
two other children --
Lazar Bojaxhiu and Age Bojaxhiu.
Lazar died in 1981,
while Age died in 1973.
They had two other children,
but they died as infants.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question is, "In what kind
of environment was Gonxhe
Bojaxhiu born and raised?"
She was born in Skopje, August 27,
1910 -- some claim August 26th --
during Turkish Ottoman rule
in an atmosphere both ethnically
and religiously diverse.
She completed the first
four years of education
at Sacred Heart Catholic
School in Skopje.
The next four years
at high school were
at state-ran public
schools also in Skopje.
She was raised with the example
of love through sacrifice
and charity initially by her
family, and secondly by the parish.
They taught her about universal
fellowship, serving God
and neighbor, especially those who
suffer physically and spiritually.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question
is, "How did she come
to the vocation of
consecrated life?"
For six years, she battled with
God, from the age of 12 until 18.
When after much prayer, counseling,
and many retreats to Letnica,
she finally decided, "I
want to be a missionary nun
to help the poor of the world."
This happened in Letnica,
Kosovo, August 14, 1928.
[ Foreign Language ]
"Why go to Kolkata, India?"
Because she had read and heard
from the fathers in Skopje
that there were missionaries in
Kolkata and throughout Bengal
in India among the poor,
the destitute, lepers,
and even among the different
faiths, casts, genders, races.
She could not remain
indifferent, but wanted to live
with them and work in their midst.
[ Foreign Language ]
"How did she travel to Kolkata,
and when did she arrive?"
The trip to Kolkata was
divided into three stages.
First, by train from
Skopje to Zagreb.
That was September 26, 1928.
Then again by train from Zagreb
to Dublin -- October 13, 1928.
Yesterday was the anniversary.
Finally, by ship from
Dublin to Kolkata
from December 1st until
January 6, 1929.
[ Foreign Language ]
In a way, this journey
of three stages reflects
and foreshadows the
three stages of her life.
First, as Gonxhe Bojaxhiu
from 1910 to 1928.
Then, as Sister Teresa of
Loreto, 1929 till 1950.
And finally as Mother Teresa,
Missionary of Love, 1950 until 1997.
[ Foreign Language ]
Those three life periods coincide
with the three theological
or divine virtues, which
are faith, hope, and love.
[ Foreign Language ]
The first period of 18 years
is characterized by searching.
Gonxhe first and foremost
sought from her parents --
her father, Kolë,
and mother, Drane.
She probed them on the meaning of
life and the significance of work.
Later, this searching continued
in the parish at Sacred Heart
in Skopje not only
among the Catholic youth
but with everyone else as well.
She was digging within the depths,
seeking the reason
for so many things.
She was relentless with
observations and findings.
She researched, analyzed, discerned.
[ Foreign Language ]
Even after she decided on her
vocation and became a Sister
of Loreto, she didn't stop there.
She looked for God,
God's will, through man
and in man -- brother, sister, God.
She constantly looked for God
in people, and always found Him.
And I believe she was
so delighted about this,
the happiest in the whole world.
Because 24 hours a day, I leave
and work with God, for God,
with humanity, for humanity.
[ Foreign Language ]
Her search continued her entire
life, at every step in every corner
of the world, in every life
situation by any means possible
with a single aim --
that man, humanity,
no longer suffers but lives.
No longer hates but loves.
Does not parish but
lives in eternity.
Her eyes, mind, and enormous
heart were always searching.
[ Foreign Language ]
For Mother Teresa,
believing means searching.
She sought and healed the ills
of the world for the poor,
justice for the rich, while loving
and giving away love,
God to every person.
After her training information
for the religious life among the
novitiates in Darjeeling (1929
until 1937) for a time,
she worked as a nurse.
Then she graduated from
university in history
and geography and worked
as a teacher.
Later, she became principal
of Saint Mary's
of the Sisters of Loreto in Kolkata.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question, "Why was she
called Sister Teresa of Loreto?"
Because, at that time, it
was custom and doctrine
to change one's baptismal name for
a new one in the consecrated life.
Gonxhe Bojaxhiu changed her
baptismal name to Sister Teresa
of Loreto because she was
part of the holy order known
as the Sisters of Loreto.
She changed her name in order to
first change herself, her life
and work, then to change Kolkata,
India, and the entire world.
[ Foreign Language ]
For nearly 20 years, she
instructed Kolkata's youth,
taught them with words, lessons,
parables, always led by the force
of faith and the inspiration
of love.
However, that did not suffice.
Everyone loved her,
respected her, admired her,
and marveled at her
life and actions.
But all at the same,
she was still searching.
She would ask herself in
the quiet presence of God
and her conscience, "Who am I?
What does God desire
for and expect of me?
What must I do here and now
for these people, for Kolkata,
for India, and all humanity?"
[ Foreign Language ]
From this faith searching then
created concern from this action,
then the first stage born from
her unbreakable mission of hope.
Mother Teresa, Missionary
of Love, the gift
and sacrifice perfectly expressed
as a continuous and complete love.
Discernment as in faith, hard work
and dedication as hope, and giving
or sacrifice as in love,
where and are the pillars
on which she centered her whole
life and throughout all of her work.
The sacrifice that amazed the world
as the Mother of Love and Charity.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question, "How
long did she live and work
as a Sister of Loreto in Kolkata?"
From 1929 until 1950 when
she received final approval
for the establishment
of the holy order
of the Missionaries of Charity.
These three phases of her life
are the substance of her life.
And without them, it cannot be
understood, let alone emulated.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question, "What
did Mother Teresa do
for Kolkata, India, and the world?"
Nothing and everything.
With the power of faith and
inspired by love, she bore witness
and confirmed that the only healing
remedy for the body and the soul
against poverty, illness, leprosy,
loneliness, and for the aged
and for the young, for all the
evil in the developed nations
and in the third world,
for all of it,
it is dynamic love
or love in action.
[ Foreign Language ]
Initially, she took on the
travels of Kolkata, later of India,
and finally of the whole world.
And she did it.
She overcame every
division and disagreement,
whether it be obstacles in
religion, nationality, race, casts,
or genders, always maintaining
her starting and ending point
of reference, the motto
-- God and men.
For her, God and men
were inseparable.
Because, above of all, she was --
in order to be and
remain Mother of All.
[ Foreign Language ]
To carry out all these
works of charity,
Mother Teresa founded the Order of
the Missionaries of Charity in 1950.
The Missionary Brothers
of Charity in 1963.
Mother Teresa's Coworkers
late in 1969.
The Missionaries of
Charity-Contemplative chapter, 1976.
The Brothers of the
Word, holy order, 1984.
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question is,
"What has she left us?"
Through Mother Teresa,
our 2000-year-old persecuted
Christianity shined
and blossomed anew, as did
Albanian Christian-Muslim interfaith
dialogue, Catholic
Orthodox-Christian dialogue.
Traditions of generous
hospitality and charity.
Helping the poor, peaceful
nonviolence,
basically our ancient values
magnified and enriched
with the great experience
of Mother Teresa.
[ Foreign Language ]
This life dedicated
to God, the church,
and people bore miraculous
fruit, especially in the creation
of a culture of life and
the advancement of charity.
In 1979, she raised us up to the
podium of the Nobel Peace Prize.
She introduced us to
the world with honor
as an ambassador of
the Albanian people.
Intervening persistently for the
protection and rescuing of Kosovo
by appealing to Pope John Paul II,
to then US President Bill Clinton,
and many other world leaders.
On the occasion of the Nobel Peace
Prize, she gave me a direct message
in our own language (in Albanian)
in front of hundreds of reporters
and later put it in writing.
I'll try and put that
in your minds in hearts.
She said, "I always keep my
Albanian people in my heart.
I pray so much to God that
His peace enters our hearts,
in all our families,
in the whole world.
Pray deeply for my poor people
and for me and for my sisters.
I pray for you.
Mother Teresa Bojaxhiu,
Oslo, October 12, 1979."
[ Foreign Language ]
Regarding the mass reconciliations
of blood feuds in Kosovo
and in the diaspora throughout 1990,
she wrote with her own hand
this message among many others
in Albanian.
"I'm spiritually tied to my Albanian
people forever in prayer and love,
especially in the most
difficult times.
After so much hardship and pain,
I'm happy without end at the news
of the reconciliations
Congratulations
to Kosovo's Albanian youth
that begun this initiative
and to all those who participate
in this grand and holy undertaking.
May 3, 1990.
In Christ, Mother Teresa."
[ Foreign Language ]
The other question that many ask or
you may ask is, "What have we gained
after the beatification and
canonization of Mother Teresa?"
Much, as she will always be
the first female Albanian saint
officially recognized and
proclaimed by the Holy See.
She whom the world declared the
universal mother and living saint
of all humanity, the Albanian
daughter, Mother of the World,
and now the Saint of Love.
This is our Mother Teresa.
She will pray and intercede on
our behalf to God while we strive
to be her worthy sons and
daughters in life and in death.
[ Foreign Language ]
Mother Teresa based life
on three major pillars.
She said, "Without love as
sacrifice, life has no meanings.
And only love will save the world."
And at the Nobel Peace
Prize ceremony, she said,
"Without love would be no peace."
And she invoked us to change our
way of life and our way of thoughts.
[ Foreign Language ]
Don Lush wants to apologize if he
-- he wants to end the presentation.
But first of all, he wants to
apologize if he took too much
of your time, and he
wants to share a moment
that he had with Mother Teresa.
And he said that she took my hand.
And then he said, "I thought
it was some sort of a game."
And she said, "Look at your hand."
And he said, "I know my hand.
This is my hand."
She said, "Look, look.
You better look at your hand.
There are five fingers."
She said, "Hold your hand and look
at it and say, 'What can I do today
for God?'" And he said,
"I said that."
And then she said,
"You have another hand.
Look at the other five fingers."
And he said, "I looked."
And then she said, "Ask with the
other hand, 'What can I do today
for man?'" And then
she said, "Continue.
During the day, go with your life.
And before you go to bed, look at
your hand, and look again and say,
'What did I do for God today?'
And with the other hand, 'What
did I do for man today?'"
[ Foreign Language ]
Her message was for all of you.
You both have two hands
with five fingers.
Ask yourselves these, and then don't
answer with words but with deeds.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Grant Harris: Do we
have room for questions?
[ Foreign Language ]
All right.
Well, wonderful, sublime.
So if we have questions
now, this would be the time.
Why don't you come up and
say your question up here?
Because we don't have
another microphone.
Is that okay?
>> I'm ignorant of
Albanian geography,
so I would like to know whether
Mother Teresa's family --
I think you spoke of the place
where her mother and father --
where the family came from.
I'm wondering if the place where her
family came from before they lived
in Skopje was in the
present-day boundaries of Albania.
I also want to ask -- I
understand that Mother Teresa
at some point met the wife of
Enver Hoxha I believe in the '80s,
and I wonder if you know
anything about that.
And I cannot resist asking also
whether you have any comment
about the honor done to the Albanian
nation and to a son of Albania
in the last week by Pope Francis
when he named an Albanian
priest a cardinal.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> Father Lush Gjergji:
The first answer.
[ Foreign Language ]
So her father was from Prizren.
>> That's in present-day Albania?
>> Father Lush Gjergji:
Present-day in Kosovo.
Prizren.
[ Foreign Language ]
It's the cultural capital of Kosovo.
Her mother was born -- the maternal
grandparents are from [inaudible]
in border with Kosovo and Albania.
Then they were moved to Novo
Sella, which is close --
[inaudible] by the way,
this is my insert here --
[inaudible] is the short name
for [foreign language],
which means rose.
So it's short name for rose.
So she was born in Novo
Sella near Gjakovës.
And then shortly after she was
born, her family moved to Prizren.
So we can easily say that both her
parents are citizens of Prizren,
which is a city in Kosovo.
[ Foreign Language ]
The second question.
Regarding the second
question, meeting the widow
of Enver Hoxha, yes,
he has knowledge.
And he says, "Yes, she did."
Nexhmije Hoxha (that's her name)
received actually Mother Teresa,
and she accompanied her to
the tomb of Enver Hoxha.
And there is apparently a
misunderstanding for many people
because Mother Teresa put
flowers at the dictator's tomb.
And it's true.
She put flowers and she
kneeled and she prayed.
And apparently when
she finished praying,
she noticed that Nexhmije
Hoxha was not feeling well,
was not feeling good.
So Mother Teresa actually reached
out, trying to console her,
trying to say that, "Look,
he thought that he was doing
something good for his country."
Because he says that her message is
that the evil cannot defeat evil.
Only good can defeat evil.
And not only that she forgave those
who gave harm, but she prayed.
And prior to that, Father said that
after she [inaudible] that feeling,
she, at that moment,
after she consoled her,
she asked where the tomb of
her mother and her sister were.
Because for those who
know the story, her mother
and the sister were separated by
her on the 13th of October, 1928,
and they never saw each other.
So a lot of damage was done there.
And I might have missed
the rest of it,
but basically that
was the context of it.
[ Foreign Language ]
Regarding now cardinal-to-be, Ernest
Troshani, he is one of the priests
that survived the religious
persecution.
So he suffered about 27
or 28 years in prison.
He's one of the priests
that are alive today
who survived the persecution.
There were about 30
of them who survived
because the rest were executed.
Two years ago when Pope
Francis visited Albania
at Saint Paul Cathedrals,
he heard first-hand witness
from this cardinal-to-be, and he
heard Ernest Troshani's story.
And the pope was very
shaken and very touched.
And if you remember,
pope got in tears.
And usually a priest would
try and kiss the hand
or kneel before the pope, and
the pope didn't allow that.
Instead, he kissed Ernest Troshani's
hand, which is something unheard of.
So this year is very
special for Albanians
because we have Mother
Teresa's canonization,
we have Ernest Troshani, which is
a martyr -- basically, he's alive,
but he is a martyr of faith.
And then we have also the 38
martyrs will be proclaimed
on November the 5th with, as
we will say, the beatification
of the martyrs, which will be
[foreign language] and others.
So the world will finally probably
know the Albanian as a nation rather
than just two states
-- Kosovo and Albania.
[ Foreign Language ]
[ Applause ]
So for those who don't
understand the Albanian,
[foreign language]
let's thank the pope
for the great honor
towards the Albanian people.
And that, yes, we have suffered,
but this is a suffering
that is not in vain.
So let's enjoy the
freedom and democracy,
but also let's appreciate
the history which is written
with the blood of the martyrs.
Because without history,
there is no future.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.